Die Gewinner von Kamath kun Hastings, Anna und ich,
würden gerne wissen, ob Sie irgendwelche
Rituale haben, bevor Sie eine Aufführung haben,
ob wir irgendwelche Rituale vor einer
Aufführung haben, äh,
ja und nein, es kommt darauf an, Sie wissen, dass ich
manchmal nur pinkeln muss, bevor wir
weitermachen  die Show,
aber ansonsten glaube ich nicht, dass ich
wirklich reichhaltiges Essen habe, wir haben Rituale
für mich, weil ich in meinem Privatleben
Pilates-Trainer
bin, also möchte ich mich manchmal, besonders bei großen Events, bevor ich auf die Bühne gehe
, dehnen und Luft holen  Aus dem
Inneren des Gefäßes Okay, erkläre, wenn
du es ganz nach unten nimmst, hast du deine
Energie so auf den Boden geschickt. Nein, sie
nehmen es ganz nach oben, genau wie das
Glühen, das zur anderen Seite tanzt
Bei jeder Show, wenn es so groß ist wie deine
Überarbeitung, habe ich das vielleicht eine halbe
Stunde lang gemacht, dann strecke ich es so aus, du
musst es tun, weil du die
Energie rundum zirkulierst, und okay, das
ist ein langer Prozess, aber du verstehst, ich
habe ein gutes Ritual, danke  Sie